has gone browse my name's Bearpaw I
wanted to make this video just to be a
hundred percent honest with you there's
some things I haven't told you bros and
I think it's gotten to a point where I'm
like I need to tell you about it I got
distracted by this picture of Alfred
that I printed out and I don't remember
why I've been doing videos on YouTube
for five years now it's something that I
love doing I'm very passionate about it
and I feel so lucky I'm not quitting
YouTube that's not why I'm making this
video don't worry
but I also love trying out different and
new things one of those things has been
to write a book if you don't know I
wrote a book it's called this book loves
you it's amazing and it took way more
time than I ever thought it would to run
a book and to make it something that I'm
really truly proud of and I think you
bros are gonna actually enjoy instead of
making someone else do all the work for
me that's been one thing but there's
also been two other things that I
haven't told me bros about that I've
been trying working really hard on to
try and make happen
I already upload two videos a day which
it's kind of a big commitment like
regardless if I'm going away I've been
to Sweden I've been to Los Angeles twice
this month like it's been crazy and
there's still been videos going up so
I've been working really really hard to
get ahead for these certain situations
so that you bros can still get videos if
you don't really follow my channel too
much you probably wouldn't even notice
the difference and I feel like that's
the reason why I'm making this video
because one other project that is gonna
happen is gonna take place in September
and I'm gonna be away for the entire
month of September pretty much that's
the commitment that I set myself out to
and one month not uploading videos I
might as well just say bye bye YouTube
because no one's gonna wait for anyone
for a month this hasn't been used to me
I've been aware of this for a long time
so basically since the last six six to
five months I've been trying to get
ahead with videos beyond these other
things that I have to travel for and
it's it's been a lot of work like I
really pushed myself really hard so that
1 September happens you bros won't even
tell a difference like it wouldn't be
even like I was away and it's come to a
point where assistant to much I feel
like it's it's stupid I shouldn't leave
you bros out of the dark I think it's
better for me to just be honest about it
so I'm gonna stop trying to get ahead
I'll probably just upload one video day
that month instead and I hope that'll be
ok no there's actually a third thing
apparently I can't even talk about the
third thing yet so forget I mention it
these are all things that are big
opportunities for me so I hope you
understand why I'm taking them like it's
hard to say no to and I'm not I'm not
approaching this as a complaint way this
is just me being honest with you press
because I love you there you go some
Brett kissing ok but I'm glad I got that
out I'm glad we did great talk by the
way this has been great thank you both
again and thank you for understanding
here's the brofist I'll see you in the
next video as always stay awesome press